what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so picking back up with the green
lantern brightest day we pick up with
the red lantern god of the red lantern
entity I like calling him red lantern
gods I think there's I think I think
calling them gods are kind of cool but
technically they're entities
ah but again you know it's actually been
a couple of weeks of course you know we
had like Emerald City Comicon and then I
came down with a really weird like a
really bad bout of food poisoning and so
on but we're back into the swing of
things so of course we'll have this and
we'll have x-men that comes out later on
today but for those of you guys who are
who have forgot a little bit about what
we talked about or who aren't really
caught up or who are new here to my
channel the idea is that you have these
entities and that's really what's taking
place in this is that somebody's
rounding up the entities the the general
gist or at least what was told to us at
the end of blackest night was that life
on Earth is really where like all life
began and so the various entities
represent these parts of the emotional
spectrum you know like fear and rage and
greed and different things like that and
that these all just sort of coalesce and
came into existence you know rage for
example came into existence the first
time that like an organism killed
another organism on earth out of rage
and like fear happened you know fear
came into existence the first time that
the first organism on earth felt fear
this is the kind of thing that took
place like over the course of like all
life across the cosmos this is how these
things began to grow and how these um
these parts the emotional spectrum began
to expand now what we also knew or at
least what we were we were told anyway
is that all these lantern entities
existed on earth we just didn't know
where and in fact this was a new thing
by Geoff Johns we knew that like
parallax was the entity or that you know
the God so to speak for the for the
yellow Lantern Corps but parallax had
long since been established in DC Comics
and so that wasn't a very new thing but
the other entities cropping up here this
was all basically fleshed out by John
Sibley saying like they all arrived here
on earth and Atrocitus the head of the
Red Lantern Corps is basically looking
for the butcher which is the Red Lantern
entity because of the fact that
Atrocitus being able to locate the
things he wants really locating the
entity itself requires the sacrifice of
blood basically what he does is he kills
people but again this is one of the
things we've talked about in the
previous videos but Atrocitus is very
much a conflicted character he's very
much a character who's stuck in this
interesting position because he's not
really like a villain I mean he is a
villain in the traditional sense you
know and the idea that like he commits
terrible things but his motivation is to
take out the guardians of the Green
Lantern's but he does value
innocent life and in fact we're gonna
see how far his conviction goes in this
particular story but basically one of
the first things he does is kill a
couple people in cop cars as well the
first thing he does is kill people and
then of course basically you know try to
locate where the where the butcher is at
where the Red Lantern entity is now from
here we switch over to a guy by the name
of Joshua Hays and Joshua Hays is
basically a guy here who stands
convicted for the murder of a young girl
and what he ends up doing is actually
taunting the father which is pretty
sadistic now again these entities go
after individuals who basically imbue
what it is they stand for so in this
instance what is up happening is a guy
named James is actually tormenting this
guy I guess uh I'm sorry Joshua's
tormenting this guy James James being
the father of this girl Elizabeth who
was killed and where Joshua basically
gives him a hard time and you know does
everything he can to basically drive
this guy up the wall to kind of drive
him nuts there suddenly met with the
arrival of the butcher who comes showing
up and really in no uncertain terms just
kind of comes smashing through a wall
but where we would expect that Joshua
would be the one who would be possessed
because he was just so evil so
vindictive so full of rage and so full
of anger the rage of the father of
Elizabeth actually Trump's that and
that's why this is cool again this is
the idea of Jeff John's writing Green
Lantern is it ties in like these
emotional themes you know no pun
intended with the overall idea of the
Green Lantern mythos it ties in like
these emotional themes these convictions
that these people are really just
genuinely filled with rage and the
butcher goes after James now in the
middle of all this really when this
starts to happen this Spectre suddenly
shows up now here's the funny thing
about this The Spectre and the butcher
at least in terms of this immediate
situation almost seem to represent the
same thing
the butcher represents like rage and
vengeance really rage more so than
vengeance but like in this instance the
butcher is possessing James because
James is so filled with rage and in turn
it would allow James to get vengeance on
Joshua for killing his daughter but the
spectre is the living embodiment of
God's vengeance it's almost as though
the The Spectre is kind of in this
position of look you're encroaching on
my territory now the spectre knows about
the butcher and he has known it for
quite some time we found that out in
blackest night but it is intriguing
because what ends up happening is the
The Spectre actually sort of starts to
fight with the butcher and actually try
to destroy the entity now remember these
entities can be destroyed I mean they're
not immutable forces it's not like you
know if you destroy them though they'll
come back or something along those lines
they're basically gone once there
but the fact remains here with this
particular scenario this is where the
things sort of share a common ground and
the sense that the butcher is is
essentially like in this massive fight
with with the specter and again it is it
is pretty interesting and it's kind of
cool but then suddenly you have the
arrival of Atrocitus now again Atrocitus
isn't really here to pick a fight with
the specter himself and all honesty I
haven't really read of an instance where
like Atrocitus and the specter have
fought in terms of the specter in his
current form and Atrocitus in his
current form uh it's not to say that
fight doesn't exist
it's only that I haven't read it yet so
I mean it may be further on down a line
in the Green Lantern mythos we're solely
just part of a story that I haven't that
I haven't caught up with yet I would
probably argue that Atrocitus wouldn't
win against the spectre but maybe he
will you know then maybe he does again
I'm not gonna swear to that I couldn't
take it as an absolute but again you
know the butcher basically possessing
James actually sees James take on this
pretty wicked form and again that's par
for the course that's what we've seen
with the lantern entities when the
entities possess a living house that
living house goes on to basically take
on a kind of humanoid form
representative of like whatever it is
that lantern entity stands for as well
as something that just absolutely looks
boss and like James looks like a beast
like it's it's pretty solid to see him
in this form but the specter kind of has
this sort of internal model or at least
a discussion of sorts with James you
know with with the role they play even
with Atrocitus himself because of the
fact that the spectre is the living
embodiment of vengeance the spectre
kills regularly that's the role at serfs
I mean it's it was designed for the
purpose of killing things but in the
spectres mind the role that it plays is
different from this particular role with
James being possessed by the Red Lantern
entity James is possessed by an entity
that's been on rage James is looking for
vengeance and so the lantern entity
takes possession of James and then James
seeks vengeance for the Spectre the role
he plays is a divine role a particular
role he plays in the universe it's not a
position he's thrust himself into the
Spectre was created by God for that
purpose so again it's kind of one of
these things of the natural order of
things versus the unnatural order of
things
and so when is it happening of courses
is you know the the specters basically
attacked by James is the Red Lantern
entity which looks awesome
and then in turn James basically kills
Joshua and that's really the end of
Joshua but from there Atrocitus steps in
and Atrocitus actually destroys this
physical form basically rips away the
shell of sorts and then basically freeze
like the butcher from the body of James
and it's kind of cool because the
butcher could easily just kind of
restructure itself or kind of bring this
body back or what-have-you but the
butcher actually looks at Atrocitus and
says well let's see what's what rages in
your heart I mean I have no need to
possess James anymore because he's
gotten the Vengeance that he seeks he
has a feel rage anymore and if that rage
is gone then there's no reason for me to
possess him and so the result is that
when it looks of Atrocitus we give it
you know a quick little three-panel
bit of his origin which again you're
welcome to check out the full-on origin
of Atrocitus to really gain a huge
understanding of what's going on but of
course you know you have the specter
step in inspector basically disables the
disables the butcher temporarily long
enough for Atrocitus to seek control of
it now this is when things get pretty
cool because when Atrocitus imprisons
the butcher inside of his own ax his own
Lantern battery from there his specter
goes to destroy James because this is
the world of the Spectre place James has
basically sought vengeance and taken an
innocent life now the fact that he was
possessed by the bull is irrelevant here
James would have killed Joshua had he
been given the chance regardless of
whether he was possessed or not and
that's the distinct difference that's
the difference between the the spectre
who would just kind of walk away and the
spectre who would take out James had the
bull possessed James and then driven
James to kill Joshua that would have
been a whole different set of events it
would have been a decision that James
didn't want to make but was forced to
but because James did this this Specter
intends to destroy him and this is where
I say we get into this cool motivation
about Atrocitus because Atrocitus steps
in and says this is fallacy this is
actually you know absolute nonsense sure
James wanted to kill this guy but James
had every reason to kill this guy now
this is where things get a little hairy
and a little ambiguous because for the
Spectre there's there's no real gray
area there there's no black and white
there's no ambiguity you are a person
who committed a terrible deed and so you
are a person who has to go done that's
it where the trosset it's it's it's kind
of like this idea that Atrocitus its
nemesis well I understand humanity
better than you do but it's not a human
factor it is a sentient living breathing
emotion feeling organism kind of thing
the spectre is just sort of an idea a
concept that Bond's itself to any one
particular being in order to
it's purpose and even the specter is non
Kippur didn't have to actually be you
know be bonded to someone they can just
kind of float out there but the specters
usually always bonded to someone and
it's always kind of cool to see that
that kind of thing happened but
Atrocitus basically says like look
you've been bonded to living host a
human host since really since like you
the earliest days of your existence and
you still don't grasp them because the
specters not designed to the specters
not designed to really understand
humanity I guess to a degree it is and
this sense of like that's why it's
bonding to host but it's never
understood humanity Atrocitus looks
around and says this is the nature of
beings people love people hate people
fall into all these different emotional
categories James desire to kill Joshua
was not based on the fact that Joshua
stole money it wasn't based on the fact
that Joshua lied you know offended him
or the woman he was with it was because
Joshua killed his daughter what father
wouldn't want to kill the man who killed
his daughter that's just the reasonable
thing to do and that's that's how
anybody would normally respond it makes
sense and so again like you know the The
Spectre sort of says okay fine then like
you know if that's how you want to be
then where do we go from here and
Atrocitus says if you want to judge him
you have to judge me first
and so the spectre does and the spectre
backs off and it's cool because the
spectre simply says this war that you're
involved in right now like you believe
that all you've wanted to do is capture
the butcher and everybody that you've
teamed up with was Sinestro and Hal
Jordan and Carol Farris and so on you
simply see this as a means to an end to
get the butcher and go about your
business but know that you're on a
collision course that Crona the the
Guardian that basically set in motion
the creation of them of the multiverse
the original Guardian that was cast out
that he's very much alive and well and
you are involved in this war with him
whether you want to be or not and so
your war against Crona is effectively a
holy war it is a war you have to be a
part of but when this war ends the time
will come when I will arrive and I will
judge you and when I do I will destroy
you now will actually have to kind of
wait and yell look into the future to
see whether or not that happens but
again it is cool and it is intriguing
because before Atrocitus who who gives
us this monologue of saying he hates
humanity he hates humans he's so much
like a human he's so much like a regular
normal being but again this is the
unique principle of Atrocitus because
among all the Red Lanterns with him
being the one that created the core he's
the only one that's really able to
maintain his autonomy I mean when
someone's forced into the Red Lantern
Corps like they basically lose their
minds
the kind of mindless beasts for the most
part is really kind of how they function
and its surface purpose because they're
just sort of cutting a swath through the
universe attacking all these different
things and it's cool to just see them
raging out like that but it is it is
interesting and I really like it in
terms of how this whole thing unfolds
and what it does and so on and so forth
but anyway guys just a quick little
one-shot story ah this will lead
directly into the war of the Green
Lantern's the the war with Cronus so
we're basically moving into the next
story arc beyond brightest tech but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rod Corps if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you